[Music]
bird watching for Lake Meads Wildlife
technicians go far beyond just passing
time it's to make sure the bald eagles
that come here for the winter season are
safe and accounted for
the bald eagle an important symbol for
the United States says our national bird
a full Wing spread would be longer than
my arms can go I think they can get up
to like six feet and there are plenty of
them hanging around Lake Mead the bald
eagles are really closely tied to water
and rivers and large Lakes National Park
Service Wildlife technician Clayton
Merrill says during the winter months
Eagles tend to come to Lake Mead because
there's plenty of food for them the bald
eagles of course are eat a lot of uh
eat a lot of fish and dive into the
water so they have a high Overlook to
look for the fish and while they're here
it's a good time to count just how many
of them there are it's part of a
national survey done every year it's a
good estimate of bald eagle health over
the entire countries this week with the
help of 41 volunteers and binoculars in
hand they spread across the lake and
counted 131 bald eagles Merrell says in
2022 they counted 151 in 2021 there were
185 Eagles but the lower count isn't
anything to be worried about as
sometimes Eagles go somewhere else in
the winter if you come across any
Wildlife during your time here in Lake
Mead The Visitor Center wants you to
take a picture and send them in
reporting in Lake Mead Victoria Saha 8
news now I'm going to go back to Bird
walk yes she is the wildlife technicians
will hand over the information gathered
at Lake Maine 2 the Army Corps of
engineer that data can often help with
any kind of lawmaking decisions when it
comes to the control of say lead which
is a major threat to Bald Eagles